- On parle d'un changement
qui est quand mê
un changement historique.
-  d date du 4 décembre était
encerclée au calendrier d'Héma-
Québec depuis septembre dernierg
plus inclusifs.
Dorénavant, l'homosexualité
n'est plus un critè h h h h h h.
LAURENT PAUL MÉNARD, directeur,
relations publiques, Héma-Québec
- Qu'on soit hétérosexuel,
Mettez l'étiquette que
vous voulez. L'évaluationdu rise
des comportements individuels.
- Les personnes qui déclareront
avoir un nouveau partenaire
sexu d depuis moins de trois
mois, ou encore plusieurs
partenaires, devront tout
simplement répondre à davavavavt
de pouvoir donner leur sang.
qui était injuste.
- La science a tranché, confirme
le docteur Martin A. Champagne,
les droits des personnes gaies.
MARTIN A. CHAMPAGNE, Ass. des
méd. hématologues et oncologues
que le don de sang pouvait
être to à à fait sécuritaire.
Le risque transfusionnel dû à un
virus comme l'immunodéficience
humaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeé
à moins de 1 sur 10 millions
d dons de sang.
- Je trouve que c'est
une très bonne nouvelle.
- Dans le Quartier gai
de Montréal, la nouvelle
est saluée.
- C'est rien qu'une ouverture
d'esprit pour les gens
Il y avait une discrimination
là-dessus.
- Je trouve que c'
Puis en même temps,
il y a telleme d de besoins
au niveau des dons de sang.
- On a besoin de 1000 donneurs
par jour.fefefefefefefefefefefel
assouplissement sur la réserve
de sand'd'Héma-Québec?
- Si on regarde le Royaume-Uni,
qui a été vraiment le premier
non genrée, il n'y a pas eu
d'impact.
- Laurent Paul Ménard voocococo,
une importante avancée sociale.
Un avis que partagent
de nombreux Québécois,
comme cette donneuse régulière.
- Je trouve que c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour
tout le monde. Pour toute
les communautés confondues.
- Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.